Israel Libanon Ägypten Jordanien wieder
Israel die deutsche chefdiplomatie auf
deeskaliierungsmission den Flächenbrand
in Nahost verhindern hart für Israel
einstehen aber den Freund auch immer
wieder an das Völkerrecht erinnern und
an das was nach einer möglichen
Bodenoffensive kommen
könnte es ist die Quadratur des Kreises
wir alle wissen dass sich unsere
Sichtweisen auf den Konflikt durchaus
unterscheiden wenn Deutschland kurz
dachte es könnte eine wichtige Rolle
einnehmen im Krieg um Nahost dann wird
es in Ciro eines Besseren belehrt nur
einen Platz in der zweiten Reihe bekommt
die oberste deutsche Diplomatin hier
beim Friedensgipfel eine gemeinsame
Abschlusserklärung scheitert berbock
muss lange warten bevor sie überhaupt
sprechen darf sie wird auch Vorort
realisiert haben dass es eben draußen
außerhalb auch Deutschlands außerhalb
Europas eine andere Sicht auf diesen
Konflikt gibt da wird eben auch gesehen
wie über Jahre Jahrzehnte hinweg die
Palästinenser gedemütigt worden sind wie
internationales Recht durch Israel nicht
eingehaltet worden ist durch den
Siedlungsbau und da kommt man so schnell
nicht zusammen die Angehörigen der
Geiseln mit deutscher
Staatsangehörigkeit erhöhen in dieser
Woche den Druck auf
[Musik]
Berlin Deutschland muss wirklich schnell
handeln uns läuft die Zeit
davon zwei usgeiseln sind inzwischen
frei mlung von Qatar verstehen sie so
verrückt ist die Welt wir kritisieren
dass der Qatar Beziehungen Z Mass hat
und dann nutzen wir aber die Beziehung
um die Geiseln frei zu bekommen wenn es
gar kein Land gäbe das Beziehung hätte
wüssten wir auch nicht wen wir bitten
sollen das zu vermitteln selbst die AFD
lobt in dieser Woche die diplomatischen
Bemühungen des Kanzlers und macht doch
eine Einschränkung es ist natürlich
nicht unser Krieg und wir sollten uns
auch doch auch in diesen Krieg nicht
einmischen wenn gleich Solidarität
angebracht ist solidarät mit die
Solidarität mit Israel das ist keine
Frage auch eine Hamas der Verbot wir ja
schon immer gefordert haben muss endlich
auch durchgesetzt werden das geht an sie
die bundesinnenministerin verspricht das
Verbot komme bald und wird ungehalten
als die CDU ihr vorwirft weiter zu viel
Zeit in Hessen statt Berlin zu
verbringen wir treffen sie auf der
Frankfurter Buchmesse ich war 3 Stunden
die Woche in Hessen ansonsten immer
überall präsent die Bundesländer sind
zuständig für die Sicherheit auf den
Straßen insofern berührt mich dieser
Punkt erstmal gar nicht und die CDU
sollte wirklich dieser Tage mehr was für
den gesellschaftpitischen Zusammenhalt
machen weil der ist dieser Tage
gefährdet wie in Neuköln Sonnenallee
eine Straße wird zum Symbol für den
drohenden
Kontrollverlust das ist wie Krieg dass
Polizisten mit Steinen beworfen werden
das Kollegen von mir mit Stangen
attackiert werden das auf mit Böller auf
uns geworfen wird W wir sind
Repräsentant des Staates und wenn das
passiert dann haben wir ein Problem mit
dem Land das Land in dem jüdische
Einrichtungen immer mehr vergittert und
überwacht werden müssen und dass seit
dem 7 Oktober deutlich mehr
antisemitische Vorfälle zählt der
Zentralrat der Juden registriert
verstärkt importierten Judenhass fällt
auf dass jetzt bei diesen
proalästinensischen Demonstrationen doch
vi deutlichere Worte kommen auch eine
andere Beteiligung mehr Menschen daran
teilnehmen und das schließe ich zurück
auf diesen vermehrten Zuzug von
arabischstämmigen Menschen in
Deutschland und hier wo heute Tausende
für Israel demonstrieren entsteht
gestern dieses Bild massenhaft geteilt
bei Social Media dutzende Muslime beten
vor dem Brandenburger Tor die CDU sieht
darin einen ungeeigneten Versuch das
Brandenburger Tor für sich zu
instrumentalisieren die Polizei klärt
den hintergrund der Aktion noch
auf und live zugeschaltet ist uns jetzt
der CDU Vorsitzende Friedrich merärz
guten Abend nach Arnsberg und damit
verbunden gleich die erste Frage Herr
März Josef Schuster hat gerade den
vermehrten Zuzug arabischstämmiger
Menschen mitverantwortlich gemacht der
größte Zuwachs an Zuwanderung mal
abgesehen jetzt von den
ukrainefüchtlingen erfolgte aber unter
unionskanzlerschaft wie groß ist denn
die Verantwortung ihrer Partei für
eingewanderten
Antisemitismus ja guten Abend Herr Koll
nach Berlin es ist in der Tat so wir
haben schon seit vielen Jahren eine
insgesamt zu hohe Einwanderung nach
Deutschland wir haben den Kurs der Union
in diesem Jahr grundlegend korrigiert
und wir machen auf dieses Problem seit
Monaten aufmerksam ich will allerdings
auch zugeben dass Ausmaß dessen was wir
hier an Antisemitismus aus diesen
zuwanderungsgruppen gesehen haben wobei
es sich nicht auf die beschränkt es gibt
ja nur noch genug deutsche die dabei
sind das Ausmaß das hat auch uns
überrascht und schockiert angesichts
dieses amaßes und der feiernden
terroranhänger auf deutschen Straßen
wurde denn beim wir schaffen das und in
den Jahren danach die antisemitische
Herausforderung durch den politischen
Islam sträflich
verdrängt wir haben immer wieder eine
Diskussion über diesen politischen Islam
gehabt es ist genug auf die Gefahren
hingewiesen worden auch aus meiner
Partei auch aus meiner
Bundestagsfraktion wir haben
Diskussionen vermieden um dieses Thema
ich gebe ihn mal ein Beispiel der viel
kritisierte Tilo Sarazin der auf dieses
Problem nun sehr deutlich hingewiesen
hat muss nicht alles teilen was er
schreibt aber auf das Problem hat er
hingewiesen und statt sich mit der Frage
zu beschäftigen hat die SPD ihn aus der
Partei ausgeschlossen und meine Partei
hat gesagt es sei nicht hilfreich ja es
wäre hilfreich gewesen auf ihn und
andere einmal zu hören und sich mit
diesem Problem etwas näher
auseinanderzusetzen schauen wir jetzt
nach vorne wir haben den höchsten
Monatswert illegaler einreisen seit über
6 Jahren wie woll wollen Sie denn dabei
künftig die Einwanderung von Antisemiten
unterbinden durch verpflichtende
gesinnungstests oder proisraelische
Verpflichtungserklärungen und was ist
mit denen die schon im Land
sind wir haben in der Tat jeden Tag um
die 1000 zusätzliche Migranten zum
großen Teil
illegal wir haben vor jetzt bald 7
Wochen vom Bundeskanzlern einer
Regierungserklärung gehört dass er den
deutschlandpakt für Migration auch mit
mit uns machen will das wird dann am
kommenden Mittwoch 50 Tage alt wir haben
sehr konkrete Vorschläge unterbreitet
ein Treffen ein Abendessen und ein
großes Interview im Spiegel war alles
was wir von der Bundesregierung bisher
dazu gehört haben wir haben Vorschläge
gemacht und insbesondere die zu schnelle
Einbürgerung muss gestoppt werden die
Koalition glaubt ja dass Einbürgerung
vor der Integration kommt bei uns ist
die feste Überzeugung dass das umgekehrt
ist erst die integr
und diese Integration müssen wir nun
spätestens nach den letzten zwei Wochen
auch an ein klares Bekenntnis nicht nur
zu unserem Grundgesetz binden sondern
auch an die feste Vereinbarung was
Staatsraison der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland ist und immer wieder genannt
wurde in den letzten Tagen nämlich eine
ohne Zweifel feste Zusage an das
Existenzrecht Israels wer das nicht
unterschreibt hat in Deutschland nicht
zu suchen das wäre eine Bedingung das
heißt eine unterschrieben
Erklärung des
Einwanderers oder wie man das dann in
der Praxis macht kann man schauen aber
dass wir nun spätestens jetzt etwas
genauer hinschauen müssen wer denn da
eigentlich zu uns kommt das ist glaube
ich nicht mehr bestreitbar und ich
dränge darauf dass wir jetzt auch hier
zu Entscheidungen kommen noch einmal wir
haben unsere Zusammenarbeit angeboten es
ist jetzt an der Bundesregierung
entsprechende Vorschläge zu machen wie
wir zusammenkommen ich warte darauf ich
habe den Bundeskanzler am Freitag noch
einmal ein Brief geschrieben ich warte
darauf dass jetzt konkrete Vorschläge
kommen wie wir uns gemeinsam an die
Arbeit machen er hat ja sehr deutlich
mit bitte um kurze Antwort gesagt wir
müssen endlich im großen Stil abschieben
ist das für sie die
Trendwende das scheint sie zu sein ob
sie das auch mit Zustimmung in der
eigenen Partei begleiten können das sei
dahingestellt es müssen aber nicht nur
konsequent abgeschoben werden die Zahlen
der Einwanderer müssen runter und der K
lassen Sie mich vielleicht zum Schluss
noch einmal sagen dass ist heute ihre
letzte Sendung darf ich das persönlich
sagen und ich glaube für viele andere
auch danke für über 30 Jahre fairen
Journalismus und das mit Stil dazu kann
man nicht bei allen sagen herzlichen
Dank damit ist der Rückweg jetzt
abgeschnitten vielen dank vielen Dank
für das Gespräch